j'ai reçu un colis chelou les amis ce
qui se passe c'est hyper excitant j'ai
reçu un mail de quelqu'un me disant
qu'ils m'avaient envoyé un colis qui
contient une escape game une escale
viennent rarement ça se passe dans une
pièce ok vous avez une heure pour sortir
de la pièce la savait dans un [ __ ] de
colis on va devoir aller chercher des
indices dehors pourquoi je dis on pas ce
que je vais pas faire ça seul il m'a dit
qu'il fallait qu'on soit 3 donc je vais
faire appel aux deux meilleurs agents de
la planète mahikari tôt
il ya vraiment un problème avec un
visage à david j'espère trouver de colis
ça se trouve c'est ça un pack collector
de voir ça se trouve c'est un gode met
les trop original comme humoriste one
avec des chiens pouvaient mois au
spectacle tous les mardi dernier au 8 de
la rue du même nom de spectacle c'est le
nom de vos spectacles exactement où le
nom de la salle les deux fois alors oh
là là là sa trousse une bombe j'ai
vraiment peur vrai que ça nous expose un
régal que le vaccin ait heures
auxquelles est ma clé mais c'est
vraiment incroyable à la mecque j'ai
trouvé la clé
ouais ouais il c'est là dans le
processeur afin d'avoir les informations
nécessaires la clé usb branché des makes
money bonjour messieurs on one ou body
vie je suis un agent de s&p et je serai
votre instructeur
lors de cette épreuve nous avons bien
votre disposition un colis ceci est un
rapport dans lequel envoyé par un agent
de la scp vous devez résoudre ce rapport
si vous arrivez à résoudre l'ensemble du
colis vous remportez votre examen et
j'aurai le plaisir de vous annoncer vous
êtes un angle lcp auquel cas ce serait
trop bien voir que c'est une imprimante
est tué il est interdit de faire usage
de la force par contre il est possible
d'utiliser navigation internet
n'oubliez pas de vous munir de votre des
ceci l'ancien officiel de la chanteuse
séverine legrix l'artère qui les
trouvaient plus tard on se retrouvera à
la prochaine est une fois vous avez
trouvé ceci
bon courage donc on a deux coffres avec
kad là aussi une carte mère
l'alimentation au caire des landes cela
fait plusieurs jours que jean qui est en
solitaire sur des apparitions paranormal
une entité qui était jusqu'à présent
qu'un simple jeu vidéo semble avoir pris
vie plusieurs témoignages
alors bon il n'ya pas vraiment la
ponctuation mais bon ça je passe
derrière plusieurs témoignages et
meurtres ont été enregistrés à l'échelle
mondiale dans les bases de données du
service hier après les deux coffres donc
auquel on n'a pas encore accès il ya la
boîte à 1,10 pour loser y est
normalement le game master thomas des
petits indices l'a vu que c'est un colis
et ce qui est bien mais pas une pièce
les mecs vont jouer aux cartes magic
sous tendent encore on a ensuite ça de
chez a marqué épreuve psychologique un
agent du s&p doit être capable de mettre
sa dignité de côté au loup vas-y vas-y
hockey s'est ouvert s'est ouvert c'est
quoi
c'est un flash light years est sûre
vas-y va le prendre parce que ça procure
un peu de plaisir
très peu ok la gare deuxième clé usb
messieurs félicitations vous avez réglé
banks usb j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que je suis
fiable en tant qu'agente jeu cp on se
retrouve souvent à devoir mettre notre
dignité de côté et vous l'avez fait la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est vous l'avez fait
pour rien
[Musique]
alors inutile légale sinon inutile non
je suis désolé ça c'est pas inutile pour
les gars nous à troll bien joué à lui
claque fly tu vas trouver des cas mais
yahia pas toutes les cartes vont
peut-être qu'on peut trier par l'accord
on va voir j'ai trouvé des morceaux de
papier qui sont en fait des lettres un
petit peu comme dans center pour ceux
qui ont joué à slender moi j'ai bien
avancé de mon côté également el ghalia
slender on est sûr et je vous ai mis en
plus c'est slender là sur la feuille et
donc je pense que c'est ce leader qui
s'est échappé du jeu vidéo envoyé un
rapport aussi de faux numéros fichiers à
trois chiffres de l'entité dans les
archives de scp où diable est une base
de données à ces faits on va taper
slender madness cp oui puisqu'elle cp
ce1 je dois aussi si vous n'avez pas les
mecs et du coup il ya toute une histoire
182 à 582 vas-y test a raison ça c'est
ouvert les mecs on a un plan il ya trois
zones aux alentours d'ici on va devoir
aller là le premier chiffre au parc
matisse giraud deuxième chiffre au
square bodin troisième chiffres au
square rené cassin tous nos baies square
quoi c'est des chiffres un peu de nature
il ya des indices à chaque fois il ya
des photos par exemple moi dans mon soir
j'ai la photo d'un [ __ ] de toboggan
pour bébé cadum les gars au liban film à
leicester
je suis désolé
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps d'attendre
david on l'a perdue rassemblés place
mais raph tu fais quoi
[Musique]
les garonnais le mode a donc le soir
bono c'est à côté au [ __ ] cette lettre
lundi
on a donc trois indices par part ouais
le premier une espèce de branchages non
dans un canton square c'est très utile
ok le deuxième un coin de bâtiments on
voit la barre ok on s'habitue à
l'effacer hockey on en mange mans qui
part qui passe à travers un grillage
ok les gars avoir go [ __ ] non mais
faut m'aider tu as un truc regarde bien
ok ouais c'est ça ok et regarde ici
c'est qu'est ce qu'on a et un truc café
as tu vois pas mouiller avec la pluie ça
c'est ok on va essayer de faire très
très doucement
il y avait du verre c'est peut-être pour
le caiap lui l' indice du coût bon les
amis mauvaises nouvelles sur l'a10 qu'on
a trouvé hier donc soit l'encré a
disparu à cause de la pluie soit c'est
un leurre et y avait rien de base
j'étais tellement content d'avoir trouvé
c'est vrai du moins c'est le bon set-up
la fin du mois qu'il ait pas mouillé
mais hyper mouillé non j'ai mis dans ma
poche mois qu'il ya du bleu rouge bleu
pour l'instant à
il a du mal à croire regarde et regarde
par effet miroir garde royale vas-y
francky david qu'il avait pris l'eau au
ja on a un chiffre égal juif canadien
en gros les gars par park il ya trois
papier mais sur les trois papiers y en a
qu'un qui contient le chiffre les
billets de ses éloges suis père
déterminés ils discutent [ __ ] les mecs
discute à ce moment là quoi alors ces
moments où il ya l'adrénaline
vous faites quoi va dit le communiqué by
the les oui il a raison
[Musique]
o la première à dix après sécurité ok
attention tu as un truc tu as un truc
8,8
le premier déjà 4 et ce con et ça vous
coûte chercher les autres pannes ont été
perdus
[Musique]
ouais au du panneau de basket
tu vois c'est sûr c'est pas toi qui vas
attraper un à temps des salaires
ok les gars c'est un truc qu'on ne peut
pas le lire quand il pleut les choses
c'est face il fallait du plastique auto
hockey trouve l'autre trouve l'autre une
sorte de palmier de la petite voix juste
avant la jeunesse est complètement
effacés
[Musique]
ok la mecque et huit autres le corps de
la le corps frêle arbitres 4 084 non
piaf 2008 château c'est vrai qu'on a
réussi en doute continue to thank la
semaine avec enfourne là
[Musique]
très bien monsieur félicitations il est
désormais des agents de gs cp
bravo
[Musique]
omer